l'assemblée nationale examine en ce
moment le projet de loi d'orientation en
faveur des handicapés
nous en parlerons dans un instant au
sénat manade weill le ministre de la
santé a présenté pour le texte sur
l'interruption volontaire de la
grossesse déjà voté par les députés a
présenté ce texte
le rapporteur du projet monsieur mézard
y est favorable
il souhaite le remboursement des
interventions par la sécurité sociale
vous avez pu l'entendre ainsi que madame
veil au cours de notre édition de 13h
refusé le texte sur l'avortement ne
résoudra rien c'est l'idée qui s'est
dégagée du rapport présenté par le
docteur jean mézard d'ailleurs le projet
de loi at-il dit n'autorise pas
l'avortement il le contrôle ministre de
la santé simone veil l'a dit l'important
est que la loi soit applicable et que
l'avortement soit un ultime recours
madame veil les sûr que si la loi est
votée cela n'entraînera pas de désordre
dans les moeurs
son intervention a été très applaudi
puis partisans et adversaires ont pris
la parole parmi eux des médecins comme
le professeur jacques enrayée adversaire
résolu de l'avortement qui dit la femme
est libre de disposer de son corps mais
pas de l'embryon qu'elles portent
maillons de la grande chaîne de
l'évolution
andré aubry communiste a demandé le
remboursement par la sécurité sociale
pierre car au su des aires a annoncé que
son groupe ne donnerait aucune consigne
de vote
pierre marcilhacy non-inscrits il n'est
de bonnes lois que celles qui ont pitié
des hommes demain fin du débat avec vote
en fin de journée